hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Finding Bigfoot do you
remember this game that I played a while
ago with various different people called
the rake well I've heard that this game
is kind of like that in that you are in
the woods and you're trying to find
evidence of that elusive beast known as
Bigfoot and he's somewhere in this
forest and I'm willing to bet he's not
too happy about being found it all
started in the spring of 2016 and the
Jasper newspapers was the announcement
of the loss of a group of terrorists in
the National Park in the police report
he was just an accident
because the band went to raft in the
river but you sure that they're
definitely implicated one of the most
elusive creatures known as Bigfoot or
Sasquatch you and your team of
researchers decide to get to the truth
oh hell yeah oh god yeah I do
Oh who is me who's me all my muscles
glasses over here am I am i Wade with a
beanie or am I am i female markiplier
here I'm gonna be I'm gonna be female
barbed wire I'm willing bad that's gonna
be good for me oh please I want to
believe let me believe okay oh my god it
is oh my god it is oh [ __ ] yeah and also
what makes it even better is this game
has multiplayer so I'm gonna be playing
this on my own right now but this game
has co-op and if it's as awesome as the
other co-op is is this made by the same
person or something because just amazing
I'm gonna need all of it where's my gun
do I have a gun I don't have a gun do I
have anything I have dick deadly
apparently go for it hello for you here
buddy boo oh there's my oh that's not
good that's a rope take tracking bullet
oh I'm out track him alright
oh I'm gonna track of who flare gun
alright I'm gonna take all this [ __ ]
because I don't know if I don't know
what the word rationing means do i needa
I need to save this for a rainy day or
something yeah that's a good stuff
military-grade oh yes more seriously I
apologize Finding Bigfoot a very serious
venture out here by myself that I did
all by my lonesome
it took min here oh I'm gonna I'm gonna
kg Matt I'm on the Cajun ma'am I
alrighty then
alrighty then I see I see well don't you
worry I've got this Oh Bigfoot Bigfoot
Bigfoot I saw Bigfoot I saw him he was
glorious she may be I don't know I don't
want to gender him or her anybody
anybody please has anybody seen Bigfoot
god damn it again just like that other
game I keep saying my footsteps or
Bigfoot footsteps
how about lake house River Laser Lake
I'm gonna go to the river alright
Bigfoot I saw you in the distance oh
don't think you can get away from me my
sniffer is the strongest sniffer ever to
go I can smell those feet from mild is
the way can I keep thinking I keep
thinking there's big food I probably
should've grabbed a weapon or something
but who needs it I don't ooh daddy's
lovely oh that's beautiful
maybe I'll see a naked SAS by Oates on
the Riverside bathing beautifully fur
glistening in the wind and Sun doesn't
know glisten in the wind anyway whatever
you know what I mean it's beautiful
just pure night pure beautiful nature
Unleashed oh that's that looks dangerous
I'll go on that yeah I'll go on that no
I do with my camera how do I use it I
don't know David no sign up by sight
words what have you got here Johnson
command Johnston kanae on
alright ok I'll buy it I'm going to
don't spin kanae on hope it's like a
canyon but it's bigger gotta watch
gourds a big crevasse alright then I'm
in a canyon apparently this is literally
exactly like the rake they were not
wrong about them hello hi that bode are
you alright are you okay just blink
twice if you're gonna be alright I see
you're doing yoga I really applaud your
betterment of yourself have you seen a
sasquatch big fail anybody alright fine
man you not helpful piece of poop I'm
gonna go on my own I'm gonna find me a
Bigfoot I'm gonna get all the credit he
thought he could share but keeping it to
himself he couldn't
I don't know words but you understand
what I mean without words cuz all we
need are emotions maybe there's no
Bigfoot to Dollywood but I've gone so
far out how am I ever gonna be able to
find my way back I'm never gonna be able
to find big food before before please a
story I'm not afraid I know your large
feet quake the ground as you walk by
it's not your fault
it's a thing of beauty and I love you
for it even though we've never met I
love you I always have I always will I
know there's a Bigfoot around here
somewhere
I can smell him her it us I just
realized something maybe I'm dumb
because I remember in the rake when you
were playing the single-player it
started out his day and then he had to
sleep and then you it was night when
you'd really hunt this high sky huge my
adventurous turned me up for nothing I
found my way back to camp but alas I
feel like it was all for naught
I've seen no sasquatch after that first
hint the glimpse The Shining rump that
was on the sasquatch
and then never again just a roar and a
tree falling and no more maybe tomorrow
will be a better day oh well they're all
lost but I'm not you sasquatch I know he
can be my friend well that paints a
picture is him being dead okay that's
that's fine then that's sad oh I didn't
even see the traps god dammit oh I
should have taken all the cameras all
right main tasks finding catch Bigfoot
what Bigfoot incase find lost Hurst if
possible well I found one of them they
were dead though so you know oh that's
what that was oh I checked him off cuz I
found him Edward Wilson alright Ben
alright ok alright so I'm gonna go play
some cameras some Bigfoot first just
over here right that's a nice camera
about over here that's pretty good we're
good I'm gonna place a trap right in
front of that hell boosts hmm the Sun is
going down
methinks it's almost Bigfoot an hour oh
yeah okay I placed my cameras the sun's
almost gone completely down and I can't
see where my bass went there's good
signs Bigfoot Sasquatch could you help
me find my bass I know you're a helpful
lovable soul so maybe you could show me
home
that'd be awfully nice of you oh there
it is I was going the wrong way easy to
do I guess in these woods when the
Bigfoots around it
oh there's my gun oh Jesus
oh goody goody gumdrops okay I can shoot
the [ __ ] out of this douchebag now
hopefully my cameras are up and running
oh they are that is lovely I love the
way that is any sign of Bigfoot they're
raining raining oh nice okay I guess
that is kind of nice
it's almost night I should have a pretty
good perimeter surrounding camera view
so let's see how this does
me any sasquatches are Dushku
anybody no all right then maybe later
yeah it's got full mobility that's
awesome ooh nice
nothing I see yet what's in the fridge
oh I have meat oh I should have baited
my traps okay well I got a few more
traps I can probably bait them going
right here let smack dab right here then
X damn it
whoops drop meat right there all right
Bigfoot's out there I'll just be taking
a nap with my little over here don't
worry about me I'm I'm doing fine
there's a Bigfoot out there they're
staying pretty quiet
it's nighttime no I can't sit in here
all day long I gotta be brave I gotta go
out there I gotta find me a Bigfoot do
that I'm not gonna be brave I think
being brave is overrated I'm gonna shoot
from the window that's what I'm gonna do
probably best fangy in this hole good
good old good old-fashioned uh [ __ ] you
to me all right I'm gonna look around
nothing okay maybe actually be braver
then I'm a big brave boy I've gotten the
best training from years of playing
horror games and talking to myself in my
own room I can deal with the solitude
deal with the scares but I can't deal
with those feet come on out don't be shy
once you get through my tough interior
you'll find that I'm a delightful teddy
bear beneath and I can only assume the
same about you come on out and give me a
big old hug
what are you afraid of your emotions
appeals
feel the passion burning I'm gonna go to
Talbot Lake that's when I haven't been
too well hey how about you oh boy
Benji come a long way down he almost got
me yes he did you all I do I'm a foot
trap down right here put this right
there all right now that went trapped
tracking with some super track bullets
okay I'll just call get my gun to make
sure it's cocked properly I mean if
there's any silver lining to this we
just confirmed that Bigfoot is in fact
real and he is really big not just in
the foot area in fact I think maybe the
feet are proportional to the rest of the
body and he's just big and you can't
fault someone for that I mean who
wouldn't be angry with a nickname like
that and it being misappropriated who is
that a bit of his blood oh that is good
maybe I can take this and sell it maybe
I can clone them that'd be nice
well I don't like this one bit I don't
like this at all I can't help it shake
the feeling that when we made eye
contact there there was a little spark
or something but maybe Sasquatch would
know give me a chance please I love you
that's an ominously timed lightning
strike for that oh well you're not what
I was looking for sorry about this Bam
Bam they get you no stop stop
dammit god dammit where'd you go god
dammit you're faster alright well I
guess I could wander out in the middle
of the lake that's a fun thing to do no
sounds Bart's gonna be able to get me
here hello what's that I just pressed a
button and got that they have a good
sense of smell and that allows them to
feel injured person or animal in a great
distance but for most efficiency it's
better to put traps on big distance from
each other fronting bear for a Bigfoot
better suit large a trap for a bear
I'll be touched drop canal I found a new
lake this seems more Marsh like good
seems like as good a place as any for a
final showdown lovely environment by the
way could use some illumination the wool
Oh fireflies Oh
and the rain stopped almost
all righty then well Bigfoot did you see
that huh
this is creepy now he's now in the
daylight you know I can be as confident
as I wanted to start shouting for
Bigfoot but now I'm actually creeping in
the middle of the night in the darkness
in a marsh and not the most comfortable
thing I've ever done no no are you
actually there are you just kind of
fakie there like I'm here like it just
remember I think I think daylight is
coming which might be my saving grace
not that he can't kill me in the day but
you know be a lot harder for him [ __ ] I
keep thinking stop that why you do my
footsteps sound like they're 10 feet
behind me
sorry there you are my beautiful home
beautiful well that's lovely that is
that's a good view okay all right then
well I'm back in my base now and I yeah
that night didn't go as well as I'd
hoped it would want clamber up to the
top of my oh they took that away because
what that was cheating was I don't know
if I'm ever gonna be able to catch
Bigfoot but the least I can do is try to
give him a chance to redeem himself I
can't seem to find him maybe you'll come
out if I use my patented Bigfoot call
hey guys Lord minion 777 here Lord
minion sevens
fear guys no dammit
huh well I see you what are you doing
what are you doing hey hey where are you
going where you going buddy boo I saw
you where you going Oh boom ha ha did I
get you son of a tit come back here you
figure your run for me I see you over
there oh I see you alright hope I got
some tracking bullets in ya oh you're
speeding I'm bid flew where you going I
got a bead on you oh did my Bigfoot call
work on you big boar gosh what are you
running from your responsibilities huh
me too
why did lets plays hey man you're quick
Jeezy quick reload dammit god dammit why
didn't I reload well i'ma get him up I
smell Bigfoot blood oh I'm gonna put
those feet on trophy hmm you're gonna be
the world's biggest stinkiest trophy and
I love it damn it Bigfoot don't run from
me you sack of [ __ ] I can't believe they
got away you're gonna I'm gonna find
that Bigfoot and what I do oh oh Jesus
oh come on fine Bigfoot don't come out
now because now be a bad time for you to
come get me I'm very damaged I'm plating
profusely out of my legs I don't
remember where base was ah he's gonna
find me before I get back yeah no oh no
Bigfoot please come on let's talk about
this let's be friends sweetie you can be
a friend ride I've been asking for that
this whole time oh god I don't remember
where my goddamn bass was hmm I don't
think I'm on the right way is that it oh
that's it isn't it is that it
that's mine right okay that's mine I
suppose it's a standoff Bigfoot I don't
think any of us are gonna win this round
oh how I want to oh how I want to be
your friend and also own you as a trophy
I think though today is just not that
day I think I've ran this out of time
for now I didn't plan accordingly
because I think I bugged the game out
with snapping the branch off before
having any traps because I couldn't seem
to trap it well enough we
the meet to get him to come by so what
I'm gonna do next time if I play this
again and I think I'm gonna play this
again is I'm gonna be better about the
traps I'm gonna be a little bit smoother
about what I'm doing it in the end I
think the Bigfoot is gonna see me for
who I really am
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] this test too
difficult for you was it mean we're
talking about what what did I hit my own
trap
I hit my own trap didn't I damnit
ok so I made a few mistakes
number one thinking that Bigfoot could
be my friend
number two giving up on Bigfoot being my
friend
number three literally everything else I
did in the game was probably a mistake
but I think I can actually do this it's
a bit more polished than the rake was
and you can't not see the solemnity
molarity so I'm thinking that this is by
the same people or the same person that
did last one um I wish I could say that
the group expedition was is on line yes
okay so the group expedition is on line
so maybe just maybe I can find my way to
Bigfoot with my friends but for now I'll
leave it at that so thank you everybody
so much for watching hope you enjoyed
this let me know what you think down the
comments below and if you found Bigfoot
more power to you better than I am
thanks again now as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]